you all know that I don't subscribe to
the polling conspiracy theories that you
can't trust polls that polling is fake
that polling is somebody in an office
making up numbers that the polls only
call old people on landlines I don't
subscribe to any of those conspiracy
theories because they're bogus and we
know that they're bogus by looking at
methodology
well done polling especially when you
average a bunch of good polls you get a
really good sense of where erases look
at 2016 Hillary was leading the national
polls by three point two she won by two
point one that's within the margin of
error that the polls were correct
nationally in 2016 now something really
dishonest was done by CNN last week with
a poll that they did and I want to call
it out CNN announced that in
battleground states Trump is winning 52
to 45 now as a savvy news consumer you
should immediately say what what does
that mean 52 to 45 across battleground
states are you saying that you added up
all of the different people in those
states and in total Trump is winning by
7 do you mean that his average lead in
each state is 7 are you waiting those
results for the populations of tho what
does that mean because states are
different populations different
electoral vote values well if you look
at page 9 of the CNN poll the
methodology page actually says for the
subset of 583 adults living in the 15
battleground states there is a margin of
error of 5.3 percentage points so first
of all you've got a sample that across
15 different battleground states is only
583 people total now that could be 38
people for state not a good sample size
some states maybe had more of that
sample and some less because of their
population and the margin of error is
5.3 so this could be essentially a tie
or Trump could be leading by 12 this
tells us very little but the most
important thing is that this poll when
it says Trump's winning in these 15
states by 7 it doesn't
tell us how far ahead Trump or Biden are
in any particular state what I mean is
Georgia's included in these 15 states
well Trump's winning by Georgia by at
around eight right now seven or eight is
Georgia even really a battleground
Georgia has 16 electoral votes it's not
really in play for Joe Biden why is it
included and how is it skewing these
results some other states that are
included are actual battleground states
like for example Nevada it's actually
sort of close Biden is +4 but Nevada
only has 6 electoral votes so how are
you waiting these different states and
what does it mean that Trump is winning
by 7 across the states this poll doesn't
have very useful information and
unfortunately it was picked up on by a
bunch of right-wing media and even some
left-wing media and it is being spread
like some kind of gospel so let's do
something that makes more sense let's
look at each state one by one and then
total up the electoral vote so when you
actually break this down Joe Biden is
winning Arizona Colorado Florida Maine
Michigan Minnesota Nevada New Hampshire
New Mexico Pennsylvania Virginia
Wisconsin and then on the other hand
Donald Trump is winning in Georgia
Donald Trump is winning in North
Carolina in Ohio the point is when you
add up the electoral votes in these
supposed battleground states regardless
of the combined population as of right
now Joe Biden would get close to 75% of
the electoral votes from these 15
battleground states now I want to be
really clear this is just a snapshot
it's a moment in time this is not about
Biden's got this it's not about staying
home in November it's not about Biden's
going to win the point is when I simply
say Trump's winning by seven in these 15
battleground states you then look at
each state you see wait a second Biden's
winning most of the states and most of
the electoral votes right now so polling
is valuable in two ways and this isn't
either of them polling is valuable to be
able to say what is one state look like
or
polling is valuable to say what is the
national popular vote looking like
giving us what seems to be a blended
popular vote for 15 states where you
call them battlegrounds but some like
Georgia are not considered battleground
states it is deceptive it tells us
nothing and it actually fuels uncritical
reporting from left right and center
media outlets that only confuses people
even more let's not fall for it that's
why it's important to understand what
was done here make sure you're following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show lastly my personal
Instagram David Pakman I took apart a
whole watermelon yesterday posted it to
my Instagram and people are losing their
minds David that's not how you break
down a watermelon David you're using the
wrong kind of knife David your hair
looks stupid David I didn't know you
were left-handed that's really betta of
you check out the watermelon video on my
Instagram David Pakman